السلطه للنساء فقط داخل هذه القريه ولا
حكم للرجال فيها بتاتا فالنساء هنا من
يتولين زمام الامور في قريه اوليمبوس
اليونانيه التي لا يتعدى عدد سكانها 38
نسمه والذين ما زالوا يتمسكون بتقاليدهم
القديمه فالرجل حين يتزوج ينتقل للعيش في
بيت زوجته وفق نظام يعود الى العصور
البيزنطيه والنساء يطلقن على انفسهن كنيه
امهاتهم لازواجهم اما الارث فلا تستفيد
منه سوى الفتيات الكبيرات في الاسره
اللاتي يحملن الاسم الاول لجداتهن من جهه
الام على عكس ما هو قائم في باقي انحاء
اليونان حيث تعطي الابنه الكبرى اسم جدتها
لوالدها ومع القرارات اليوميه التي تتخذها
النساء في القريه فانهن ايضا يعملن في مهن
صعبه بمفردهن مثل الخياطه وتحضير الخبز في
الافران والزراعه بعدما هاجر رجال القريه
الى الولايات المتحده ودول اوروبيه اخرى
بدءا من خمسينات القرن الفائز